When Yibin describes what it was like to grow up in a town in the Gobi Desert, just first the simple physical hardship of it. Harsh winters. Summers so hot the asphalt on the road would melt and get on her white school uniform, she says. This is China in the 1970s. Her town, Jiuquan, had a big factory that made products out of metal and steel. There were some really poor farms. Yibin's dad had a job that was better than most, Yibin says. He led the musicians for the local song and dance ensemble, making shows for the government, basically propaganda. They would tour to smaller towns. When she turned four and a half, her dad told her, you're going to learn to play an instrument. And she started on the violin. It wasn't until she got older that he explained why.
当依彬描述她在戈壁沙漠小镇成长的经历时，首先提到的就是最基本的物质艰辛。严酷的冬天，夏天的炎热让柏油路都会融化，粘在她的白色校服上。那是1970年代的中国，她的家乡酒泉有一家大型工厂，生产金属和钢铁制品。还有一些非常贫穷的农场。依彬说，她父亲的工作比大多数人都要好，他带领当地歌舞团的音乐家，为政府表演节目，基本上就是宣传演出。他们会到更小的小镇巡演。在她四岁半时，父亲告诉她，她要学习一种乐器。于是她开始学小提琴。直到她长大后，他才解释了原因。
He doesn't want me to have a job that has to be under the sun, in the factory with my hands, with heavy labor.
他不希望我从事那种必须在太阳下、在工厂里靠双手做重体力劳动的工作。
And then would your dad tell you you have to do this because this is your future?
那你父亲当时有没有告诉你，你必须这样做，因为这是你的未来？
Yes.
是的。
He would.
他会这么说。
What would he say?
他会怎么说？
I remember one time when he took me to the market. There are people selling garments on the street. It was really hot. And he says, look, if you don't practice, you're going to work here. Did you see that girl? She was trying to help her dad to sell a pair of pants. Do you want to be here? I thought, oh, so hot. I can't stay there.
我记得有一次他带我去市场。街上有人在卖衣服。天气非常热。他说，看，如果你不练习，你就会在这里干活。你看到那个女孩了吗？她在帮她爸爸卖裤子。你想待在这里吗？我想，哦，太热了。我不能待在那儿。
And did that motivate you? Would you think about that, and it would keep you practicing?
那这激励你了吗？你会想到这些，然后让你坚持练习吗？
No.
没有。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
She was a kid. She hated practicing. And dad had her doing like two hours a day and four or five hours on days there wasn't school. Sometimes while she practice, she'd put rubber bands around the chair legs and do Chinese jump rope. Other times--
她当时还是个孩子。她讨厌练习。父亲让她每天练习两个小时，不上学的日子则要练四五个小时。有时候她在练习时，会把橡皮筋绑在椅子腿上玩跳皮筋。还有的时候——
I was just playing the comic books I put on a music stand.
我只是在玩放在乐谱架上的漫画书。
You were playing the comic books? What do you mean?
你在玩漫画书？这是什么意思？
No, I was flipping comic books. I would just play, and I would flip the comic book on my music stand. And I set the alarm maybe half an hour before Mom comes home and then squeeze my skin to make it very red. So when she comes in, I said, look, I practice two hours.
不，我是在翻漫画书。我就在那里拉琴，然后翻动乐谱架上的漫画书。我会在妈妈回家前大约半小时定好闹钟，然后挤捏我的皮肤让它变得很红。所以当她进来时，我说，看，我练习了两个小时。
You mean you squeeze the skin on your neck.
你是说你挤捏脖子上的皮肤。
Yeah. So it--
对。所以它——
Where the violin rests.
小提琴搁放的地方。
--looks red, I said.
——看起来很红，我说。
Yeah.
是啊。
Fortunately, she had a good ear and natural skill. And her dad, she says, was a patient and kind teacher. But to turn her into a musician, she and her dad faced some pretty daunting and extraordinary challenges. All this was happening during a very particular moment in China, during the Cultural Revolution.
幸运的是，她有很好的乐感和天赋。她说，她的父亲是一位耐心且仁慈的老师。但为了把她培养成一名音乐家，她和父亲面临着一些相当艰巨且非同寻常的挑战。这一切都发生在中国一个非常特殊的时期，即文化大革命期间。
Starting in the 1960s, Western classical music was banned in the country. It couldn't be performed or played on the radio. Violins and pianos were smashed or burned. Her dad, who loved Western classical music, would stay up late at night to hear it on Russian radio stations. He knew Yibin wouldn't be allowed to play this kind of music in public, but violins were permitted in China if you were playing revolutionary music. Now, from the beginning, to send her down this road of becoming a musician, he had to be incredibly resourceful. He just had to jump into battle just to get her violins to play. He found one in a school warehouse in a nearby town where old instruments were locked up. Another he secretly saved from a fire where it was going to be burned. And then he had his next obstacle.
从1960年代开始，西方古典音乐在全国被禁。它不能被演出，也不能在广播中播放。小提琴和钢琴被砸碎或烧毁。她的父亲热爱西方古典音乐，会熬夜在俄国电台收听。他知道依彬在公开场合是不允许演奏这类音乐的，但在中国，如果你演奏革命音乐，小提琴是被允许的。从一开始，为了让她走上成为音乐家的道路，他必须非常有办法。为了给她弄到小提琴，他不得不奋力拼搏。他在附近一个小镇的学校仓库里发现了一把，那里锁着旧乐器。另一把则是他从火堆中秘密抢救出来的。随后，他遇到了下一个障碍。
If it's so hard to get a violin, where do you get the music?
如果小提琴都这么难弄到，那乐谱是从哪里来的呢？
He hand-copied music he borrowed from his friends. In his organization, there were violinists. They were all some sort of self-taught.
他亲手抄写从朋友那里借来的乐谱。在他的单位里有一些小提琴手。他们都是自学成才。
They had these books of etudes for beginners that they'd hand-copied from someone else, who'd hand-copied them from someone else, each book 80 or 90 pages long. Neighbors hearing this stuff didn't recognize it as Western music. Just sounded like exercises.
他们有这些手抄的初学者练习曲集，是从别人那里抄来的，而那个人又是从另一个人那里抄来的，每本书有80到90页长。邻居们听到这些东西，并没认出它是西方音乐，听起来就像练习曲。
Yeah. He borrowed from everybody. Do you have a book five? Do you have book four? He would just spending time at night just hand copy.
对。他向所有人借。你有第五册吗？你有第四册吗？他晚上会花时间亲手抄写。
Your father would.
你父亲会这么做。
Yeah. I saw him copying. I was fascinated. He would cut the pen diagonal, and then he put the ink in. And the thick edge, if you put it down, would be already a note.
是的。我看到他在抄写。我很着迷。他会把笔尖斜着剪开，然后蘸上墨水。如果用力按下粗的那一端，就是一个音符。
Oh, because it would make a black dot.
哦，因为那样会形成一个黑点。
Yeah. He'd just go like that. He said, look, this is very fast. This is a flat. This is a sharp. And then quickly, if you go quick, the lines are very straight. You can't be slow. You can't shake your hand.
是的。他就是那样做。他说，看，这个很快。这是一个降号。这是一个升号。如果动作快，线条就会很直。你不能慢。你的手不能抖。
Then, in 1977, Yibin's seven years old. She gets home from school, and her dad is all excited.
然后到了1977年，依彬七岁了。她放学回家，父亲非常兴奋。
He says, come, come. I have something to tell you. I thought I was in trouble. He says, no, no, no. We're going to audition for Xi'an Conservatory.
他说，来，来。我有事要告诉你。我以为我闯祸了。他说，不，不，不。我们要去参加西安音乐学院的招生考试。
A year after Chairman Mao's death, China's music conservatories were open again and holding auditions. Suddenly, playing the violin could open up a whole world to Yibin, a world far from their town in the Gobi.
毛主席逝世一年后，中国的音乐学院重新开放并开始招生。突然间，拉小提琴可以为依彬打开一个全新的世界，一个远离戈壁小镇的世界。
He says, if you get in, then that would be great. You have your future.
他说，如果你考上了，那就太好了。你就有未来了。
Did he want you to get out of the Gobi Desert area, though?
但他当时想让你离开戈壁沙漠地区吗？
Yes.
是的。
So was his goal you'll play the violin, and then you'll end up in some big city somewhere?
所以他的目标是你学会拉小提琴，然后去某个大城市？
Yes. Then I'm on my way. In a big city, it's class up.
是的。然后我就有出路了。在大城市，层次就更高了。
If she aces this audition, she'll be in Xi'an, one of the largest cities in the country. It could get her into a big city orchestra or get her into university, which would be nearly impossible otherwise, coming from where she came from. And so this became their single-minded goal.
如果她能通过这次考试，她就会去西安，这是国内最大的城市之一。这能让她进入大城市交响乐团或考上大学，如果从她出生的地方来看，这几乎是不可能的。于是，这成了他们孤注一掷的目标。
And I'm telling you this story because this is This American Life from WBEZ Chicago, and our whole show today is about people who set out on some path, and they are ripped off that path by bad luck, by fate, by mistakes they made that they didn't even know they were making, and then they have to fight and claw their way back. The biggest thing to throw Yibin off course is still to come and is one where her father is really left with no options, where he has to try and invent something out of absolutely nothing to fix things and get back on course. Stay with us.
我讲这个故事是因为这是来自芝加哥WBEZ的《美国生活》节目，我们今天的整个节目都是关于那些踏上某种道路，却被厄运、命运、或者是他们自己都不知情的情况下犯下的错误从那条路上拽下来，然后不得不拼命挣扎着爬回去的人。依彬偏离轨道后遇到的最大障碍还在后面，那是她父亲几乎别无选择、不得不从无到有创造出什么办法来解决问题并重回正轨的情况。请继续收听。
OK. So Yibin's dad tells her about these auditions when she's seven years old. But the conservatory in Xi'an, it's a middle school, and so she can't actually audition till she's old enough for middle school. That day finally comes. She's 11 and 1/2 years old. It's 1981 when she finally gets her chance to grab at this special future that her dad has been preparing her for for years, though before they can do that, they have one rather serious obstacle to overcome first. They don't have enough money for train tickets to get to Xi'an for the audition or for a hotel.
好的。依彬的父亲在她七岁时告诉她这些考试的事。但西安音乐学院是一所中学，所以她必须等到到了中学年龄才能参加考试。那一天终于来了。她11岁半了。1981年，她终于得到了机会，去抓住父亲多年来一直为她准备的那个特别的未来，尽管在此之前，他们必须首先克服一个相当严重的障碍。他们没有足够的钱买去西安参加考试的火车票，也住不起酒店。
So Dad gets relatives to donate some money, he sells off stuff from their house, and there was some money from when his dad died that had never been distributed. Getting some of that money led to a squabble with his older brother that lasted for years. But at the end of all that, money in hand, one spring day, Yibin and her dad headed off on the train. The ride to Xi'an took 36 hours, a trip unlike anything she'd ever taken in her life. First time leaving her part of China. First time visiting a big city. And what does she remember? The thing she brings up right off the bat when we talk about it--
于是父亲找亲戚捐了一些钱，卖掉了家里的东西，还有他父亲去世后一直没分配的一笔钱。拿到那笔钱导致他与哥哥发生了持续多年的争执。但最终，钱到手了。一个春天，依彬和父亲踏上了火车。前往西安的路程耗时36小时，这趟旅程是她一生中从未经历过的。第一次离开她所在的中国区域。第一次造访大城市。她记得什么呢？当我们谈到这个时，她立刻提到的是——
I was very excited because my dad would give me steamed cake. Each bag has 12. It was very brown.
我很兴奋，因为我爸爸会给我蒸蛋糕。每袋里有12个。颜色很深。
What is steamed cake? I don't know what that is.
什么是蒸蛋糕？我不知道那是什么。
Steamed cake, basically, made of egg and flour, sugar. And they're very fluffy, and has the smell of eggs.
蒸蛋糕，基本上就是鸡蛋、面粉和糖做的。非常松软，有鸡蛋的香味。
And you never had this back home.
你们在老家从来没吃过这个。
I saw it in the store, but we don't buy very often. But there, that's all for me. [LAUGHS] Each morning breakfast, I get to eat two.
我在店里见过，但我们不常买。但在那儿，那都是给我的。[笑声]每天早上早餐，我可以吃两个。
And then you had never been away from the Gobi Desert, right?
而且你以前从未离开过戈壁沙漠，对吧？
No.
没离开过。
So what was it like? What were your impressions of the city?
那你感觉如何？你对这座城市的印象是什么？
My god. By the last, I think, last six hours, we enter Xi'an. Everything was green, and we open the window. The air was moist. I remember our heads were sticking out of the window. I said, wow, can you breathe this? And the mountain, the hills, were all covered with green. We were both thinking, wow, so many trees.
天哪。我想在最后六小时左右，我们进入了西安。一切都是绿色的，我们打开窗户。空气是湿润的。我记得我们的头都伸出窗外。我说，哇，你能呼吸到这个吗？山丘上全都覆盖着绿色。我们俩都在想，哇，树真多啊。
In the train station, they were selling fresh fruit she'd never seen. Pomegranate. Persimmon.
在火车站，他们卖着她从未见过的新鲜水果。石榴。柿子。
And we stayed in the hotel. I'd never been to a hotel. And then I got very excited. I thought, this is a great life if I live here.
我们住进了酒店。我从来没住过酒店。我很兴奋。我想，如果住在这里，生活该多美好啊。
The hotel was close to the conservatory and noisy, she says, with the sounds of kids' instruments, filled with parents and kids who were also auditioning. She and her dad started to get nervous.
她说，酒店离音乐学院很近，到处是小孩子练琴的声音，住满了同样来参加考试的家长和孩子。她和父亲开始紧张起来。
And then he went to our neighbor next door and the girl from just bigger town next to Xi'an. But her father played in the orchestra. And she had nice clothes, and her father knows all the repertoire. And then they had a book.
然后他去找了隔壁的邻居，那个女孩来自西安隔壁较大的镇。但她父亲在乐团里演奏。她有漂亮的衣服，她父亲知道所有的曲目。他们有一本书。
Like a printed book.
像是一本印刷的书。
Printed book. And the first time, my dad says, can I see your book? And he took the books and said, oh, I have never seen the book.
印刷的书。第一次，我爸爸说，我能看看你的书吗？他拿过书说，哦，我从来没见过这本书。
He had never seen printed music in a book?
他以前从没见过书里的印刷乐谱？
Yeah. Western composers book.
是的。西方作曲家的书。
That music had been banned. He'd seen books of Chinese music, which uses a different notation. Yibin made it through the first round of auditions, and the second round. After that, not many kids were left in the hotel.
那种音乐曾被禁。他见过用不同记谱法的中国音乐书籍。依彬通过了第一轮考试，然后是第二轮。之后，酒店里没剩几个孩子了。
The hotel was very quiet, I remember, at the breakfast.
我记得早餐时，酒店非常安静。
15 violinists were left. Yibin was the very last one to play for the judges.
还剩下15名小提琴手。依彬是最后一个为评委演奏的。
I remember I walked into the room. It was a big room. There were six people on the panel. I was very confident because I get to play with the pianist the conservatory provided. I remember I really enjoyed having the piano to play. I thought, wow, listen to that sound. I sound so good with piano.
我记得我走进房间。那是一个大房间。评审团有六个人。我很有信心，因为我可以和音乐学院提供的钢琴伴奏一起演奏。我记得我真的很喜欢有钢琴伴奏。我想，哇，听听那个声音。有了钢琴，我拉得真好。
Because you never heard yourself do that.
因为你从来没听过自己那样演奏。
No. I never played with a pianist. And we were very confident. I thought the concerto was so well prepared. I also like the concerto because it has a melody. There's a technical part. You can show off.
没有。我从来没跟钢琴伴奏合作过。我们很有信心。我觉得协奏曲准备得非常好。我也喜欢这首协奏曲，因为它有旋律。还有技术部分。你可以炫技。
[MUSIC - "VIOLIN CONCERTO IN A MINOR" BY JB ACCOLAY]
[音乐 - JB·阿科莱的《A小调小提琴协奏曲》]
This is Yibin basically sight reading for me the concerto that she played that day by JB Accolay. She's also played the other solo violin pieces we've heard in this story. Anyway, so at the audition, she's playing, feeling great. Barely a page in--
这基本上是依彬在为我视奏她那天演奏的JB·阿科莱的协奏曲。她也演奏了我们在这个故事中听到的其他独奏小提琴曲。总之，在考试时，她演奏着，感觉很棒。刚拉了一页——
Someone in the panel clap their hand and says, OK, that's it. Thank you. You can go. I was shocked because the best part, I haven't reached there yet. I look at them. I saw them talking. One teacher, I remember, he had a double chin. He was shaking his head. I saw the chin was moving. And I heard he says, no, no, no. It's just impossible. We don't need to hear more.
评委席上的某个人拍了下手说，好了，就这样。谢谢。你可以走了。我很震惊，因为最精彩的部分我还没拉到呢。我看着他们。我看到他们在交谈。我记得其中一位老师有双下巴。他在摇头。我看到他的下巴在动。我听到他说，不，不，不。这简直不可能。我们不需要再听了。
And then what?
然后呢？
I walked out of the room. I remember I was terrified. I thought, my dad's dream is over.
我走出了房间。我记得我吓坏了。我想，我爸爸的梦想破灭了。
She says she also thought, I'm 11 and 1/2. No more green city. No more hotel. No more excitement. Her dad was waiting for her in the hallway.
她说她当时也想，我才11岁半。再也没有绿色的城市了。再也没有酒店了。再也没有兴奋了。她父亲在走廊里等她。
He was like, so how did it go? I said, Dad, I think-- I think I did very bad. They asked me to leave. He says, but maybe you were good enough. They don't need to hear more. I said, no, no, no. One man was shaking his head. He says, no, it's not possible. My dad was so-- he held his fist, hammering on the edge of the window. The sound was behind him.
他问，考得怎么样？我说，爸爸，我想——我觉得我拉得很糟。他们让我走。他说，但也许你已经足够好了。他们不需要再听了。我说，不，不，不。有一个人在摇头。他说，不，这不可能。我爸爸非常——他攥紧拳头，用力锤着窗框。声音就在他身后。
He says, there got to be a way. Got to be a way. Then in Chinese he says, [SPEAKING CHINESE]. What's the solution? What's the solution now? Got to be a way. I looked at him. I felt terrified. I thought, I disappointed him. He says, have to find a way. You wait here, he said. I said, don't go.
他说，一定有办法的。一定有办法。然后他用中文说，[中文发言]。有什么解决办法？现在有什么办法？一定有办法的。我看着他。我觉得很害怕。我想，我让他失望了。他说，一定要找到办法。你在这里等，他说。我说，别走。
Why did you try to talk him out of whatever this is?
你为什么要试图劝阻他去做什么？
Because I was embarrassed. I don't want to be more embarrassed when people tell him how terrible I was. I said, I-- I really didn't do well. It's my fault. I'm very, very sorry. He said, did you make a mistake? I said, I don't know. He said, just wait here.
因为我很尴尬。当别人告诉他我拉得有多糟糕时，我不想让他更尴尬。我说，我——我真的没拉好。是我的错。我非常、非常抱歉。他说，你犯错了吗？我说，我不知道。他说，就在这儿等着。
Let me just remind you. Most people, you fail your audition, it's over. Not her dad. He went into the classroom where the auditions were, and outside the room a college student was packing up papers because Yibin was the last audition. She follows, violin in hand.
让我提醒你们。大多数人，考试失败了就结束了。但她爸爸没有。他走进了考场，门外一个大学生正在整理文件，因为依彬是最后一个考生。她拿着小提琴跟了上去。
I heard my dad. He says, could she play again? If she was so terrible, can you talk to them? The guy says, no, I don't think so. It's over. And my dad says, but what happened? Can you find out? The guy says, I can't go in to talk. I'm a student. I only work here. Then my dad says, you know, we took train 36 hours. You know where I'm from?
我听到我爸爸的声音。他说，她能再拉一次吗？如果她真的那么差，你们能跟他们谈谈吗？那个人说，不，我觉得不行。结束了。我爸爸说，但到底发生了什么？你能查一下吗？那个人说，我不能进去谈。我只是个学生。我只在这儿工作。然后我爸爸说，你知道，我们坐了36小时火车。你知道我是从哪儿来的吗？
The guy didn't answer. He said, I'm from Jiuquan. The guy says, oh. You know, my uncle lived in town nearby. I know Jiuquan. My dad says, so you know. You know how hard this is. And I think the guy, young guy, had a little soft spot for that.
那个人没回答。他说，我从酒泉来。那个人说，哦。你知道吗，我叔叔住在附近的小镇。我知道酒泉。我爸爸说，那你懂的。你知道这有多难。我想那个小伙子对此有一点同情心。
Her dad says, can you just ask them to give her another chance? At least let her play to the end of the concerto. The guy says, I don't think I can do that. But I have to turn in these papers. I'll find out what happened with her.
她爸爸说，你能请他们再给她一次机会吗？至少让她把协奏曲拉完。那个人说，我想我做不到。但我得去上交这些文件。我会查一下她到底出了什么问题。
So we waited outside. I don't know how long. I just thought it was so hopeless, why my dad is embarrassing me. The guy came out, told my dad, they told me that she has good posture. She has good intonation. But she played many wrong notes. That's not acceptable. My dad says, what do you mean, wrong notes? I'm a musician. I correct every note. I played it with her, practice with her. I know every note.
于是我们在外面等。我不知道等了多久。我只觉得太绝望了，为什么我爸爸要让我丢脸。那个人走出来，告诉我爸爸，他们说她姿势不错。音准还可以。但她拉错了很多音。这是不可接受的。我爸爸说，你什么意思，拉错音？我是音乐家。我纠正了每一个音符。我和她一起拉，一起练习。我了解每一个音符。
The guy says, but maybe you don't read music well. Maybe you were wrong. He said, wait, I can show you the score. Every note is correct. So he run back to his bag, then took the music, the hand-copied sheet music, came over. He was basically begging. He says, please, please. I can't go back home like this. This is my only chance, our only chance.
那个人说，但也许你的乐谱看不准。也许是你错了。他说，等等，我能给你们看乐谱。每一个音都是对的。于是他跑回包里，拿出乐谱，那些手抄的谱子，走了过来。他基本上是在乞求。他说，求求你们，求求你们。我不能就这样回家。这是我唯一的机会，我们唯一的机会。
He says this to him? It's our only hope?
他对他说了这话？这是我们唯一的希望？
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. You, you are lucky. You study in the conservatory. But do you know how many people study in the conservatory from our hometown? None. Violinist? None. Please, just help me.
是的。是的。是的。你，你是幸运的。你在音乐学院学习。但你知道我们老家有多少人在音乐学院学习吗？一个都没有。小提琴手？一个都没有。求求你，帮帮我。
Her dad hands the student the score, and he looks at it.
她爸爸把乐谱递给学生，他看了一眼。
He was surprised. He saw the score was all hand-copied. He says, did you copy this? Who wrote this? He says, me. But who you copied from? He says, my friend. But where the score came from? He said, I don't know.
他很惊讶。他看到谱子全是手抄的。他说，这是你抄的？谁写的？他说，我。但你是从谁那儿抄的？他说，我朋友。但谱子从哪儿来的？他说，我不知道。
The student says, wait a minute, and goes back into the audition room. This time he's gone for longer.
学生说，等一下，然后又回到了考场。这次他走了更久。
I remember my dad was not looking at me. He would just swallow. And then this time, one violin teacher came out. It was not the one with double chin. He says, come over here. Did you play from this copy? I said, yes. And he asked my dad, that's your hand copy? My dad said, yes. You know there are many wrong notes, right?
我记得我爸爸没有看我。他只是咽了咽口水。这次，一位小提琴老师走了出来。不是那个有双下巴的。他说，过来。你是照着这个副本拉的？我说，是的。他问我爸爸，这是你的手抄谱？我爸爸说，是的。你知道有很多错音，对吧？
My dad says, no. I don't know. I copied right. I correct-- checked many times. I don't think it's wrong. But the teacher said, but she played many wrong notes. It's from this score. This is the wrong key. There's no F sharp. But here, you are missing a flat, and there's many mistakes. My dad says, but that's all we had. My dad says, can you let her play-- finish-- if she didn't play well?
我爸爸说，不。我不知道。我抄得很对。我纠正了——核对了多次。我不觉得是错的。但老师说，但她拉错了很多音。就是从这本谱子来的。这是调号错了。没有F升号。但这里，你漏了一个降号，而且有很多错误。我爸爸说，但这就是我们仅有的了。我爸爸说，能让她拉完——如果她没拉好的话？
He says, no, no, no. It's not about that. There's no second chance. We don't give a second chance. There's no second audition. It's not fair to other people. My dad was so hopeless. He says, OK. I will talk to my colleague. My dad says, will you give her a chance? He says, no, don't ask question like that. I'm not going to say anything. Dad says, but how many you will keep out of 15? He says, nine.
他说，不，不，不。不是这个问题。没有第二次机会。我们不给第二次机会。没有第二次考试。这对别人不公平。我爸爸太绝望了。他说，好吧。我会跟同事商量。我爸爸说，你会给她机会吗？他说，别问这种问题。我什么都不会说。爸爸说，但15个人里你们要留多少？他说，九个。
Six will get in, he says, and then three backups.
六个录取，他说，还有三个候补。
That's all I can say. Now you have to go.
我只能说这么多了。现在你们得走了。
What happened then?
然后发生了什么？
We went back home. There was two weeks of wait.
我们回了家。等了两周。
Did you think you had any chance at all?
你觉得你还有机会吗？
I was completely hopeless. One day he got a telegraph from the post office.
我完全绝望了。一天，他从邮局收到了一封电报。
Telegram, yeah.
电报，没错。
Oh, telegram. One sentence. Yibin Li is selected, congratulations. He had that telegram in his hand. He read it many, many times. Read to my mom. Read to me. He was shaking. He says, I can't-- unbelievable.
哦，电报。只有一句话。李依彬被录取，恭喜。他手里拿着那张电报。他读了很多、很多遍。读给我妈听。读给我听。他在颤抖。他说，我不能——难以置信。
He couldn't help himself, had to reach out to the school. Wrote a letter to the admissions office thanking them, saying how grateful and overjoyed they were.
他控制不住自己，不得不联系学校。写了一封信给招生办公室表示感谢，说他们是多么感激和欣喜若狂。
And he asked, how come you picked her? The guy working at admissions was a very nice man. He was about retiring. For some reason, he took moment to wrote letter to my dad. He says, I had sympathy. I heard your story. We were shocked about hand-copied each note, and I'm very touched. By the way, she got in because three other kids did not pass Chinese and math exams. She's on the bottom, but she's in. Congratulations.
他还问，你们为什么选了她？招生办的那个人是个非常好的人。他快退休了。不知为什么，他花时间给我爸爸回了信。他说，我很有同情心。我听了你的故事。我们对手抄的每一个音符感到震惊，我非常感动。顺便说一句，她被录取是因为另外三个孩子没通过语文和数学考试。她是垫底进来的，但她进了。恭喜。
In other words, she was on the waitlist, number nine of nine kids. Then three kids didn't have the academic qualifications to enter the school, so she got in.
换句话说，她在候补名单上，是九个孩子里的第九名。然后三个孩子没达到学校的学术要求，所以她进了。
That's how I got in. I was lucky.
我就是这样进去的。我很幸运。
I mean, it's interesting. Your dad puts you on a path starting when you're like 11 and 1/2, and everything is going perfectly. And you're at the audition, and then everything gets thrown off course. And then your dad just fights and fights and fights, grabs at any straw, and he just wills you back on course. Have you thought about that moment very much in the years since?
我是说，这很有趣。你爸爸在你11岁半时把你领上了这条路，一切进展完美。然后你在考试时，一切偏离了轨道。接着你爸爸只是拼命地战斗，抓住任何一根救命稻草，硬是把你拉回了正轨。这些年来，你有回想过那个时刻吗？
I always think my dad made me. Without him, I wouldn't be me. I don't know what the other life could be. I don't know. But I love what I have. I mean, I'm so lucky, doing what I love to do. It's all because of my father.
我一直认为是我爸爸成就了我。没有他，就不会有今天的我。我不知道另一种生活会是什么样。我不知道。但我热爱我现在所拥有的。我是说，我很幸运，能做我热爱的事情。这全是因为我的父亲。
From the conservatory in Xi'an, she graduated and went to an even better conservatory for college in Shanghai. She graduated there and joined the faculty there, came to America, studied at Juilliard, now is in New York. When she first came to America, her father cried on the bus to the airport, thinking he'd never see her again. The way he saw it, she was in a dream job in Shanghai. Why would she ever leave it? But then, her parents moved here in 2016. Her dad died two years ago. Today, Yibin performs and records and teaches and has a 15-year-old daughter of her own.
从西安音乐学院毕业后，她又去了上海一所更好的音乐学院读大学。毕业后她留校任教，来到美国，在茱莉亚学院学习，现在在纽约。当她刚来美国时，她父亲在去机场的巴士上哭了，以为再也见不到她了。在他看来，她在上海有一份理想的工作。她为什么要离开呢？但后来，她父母在2016年搬到了这里。她父亲两年前去世了。今天，依彬表演、录音、教学，并且有一个15岁的女儿。
Have you had moments with your daughter where you felt like, OK, you need to jump in the way your dad did with you to save the day, to make her future?
你和你女儿在一起时，有没有觉得，好吧，你需要像当年你父亲对你那样挺身而出，去拯救局面，去创造她的未来？
No.
没有。
Why?
为什么？
She grew up in New York City. She can have any cake she wants.
她在纽约市长大。她想吃什么蛋糕都可以。
Her daughter plays the violin, but if she wants she can sign up for flute. If that doesn't work out, she can do martial arts. If that's not right for her, she can try something else, whatever she wants. That's the life Yibin wants for her, one where everything doesn't ride on a single audition, make or break, your whole future, with six strangers in a room on some random spring morning and your dad there to protect you.
她女儿拉小提琴，但如果她想，她可以报名学长笛。如果那行不通，她可以练武术。如果那不适合她，她可以尝试别的，无论她想做什么。那就是依彬为她想要的未来，一个不会把一切都押在一次面试上，不是成败在此一举，不是把你的整个未来交给房间里六个陌生人，而且是在某个随机的春日清晨，还要你父亲在那里保护你。
Coming up, a 17-year-old girl starts swimming into the open ocean and ends up somewhere so different from what she'd planned on. That's in a minute from Chicago Public Radio when our program continues.
接下来，一个17岁的女孩开始游向公海，最终到达了一个与她计划完全不同的地方。一分钟后，芝加哥公共广播电台节目继续播出。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Today's program, "Off Course," stories of people-- and as you'll hear, not just people-- who get thrown off the very clear course that their lives were on and then have to invent what they're going to do next. We've arrived at Act Two of our program.
这里是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。今天的节目《偏离轨道》，讲述人们——正如你将听到的，不仅是人们——偏离了原本清晰的生活轨迹，然后不得不去发明他们接下来要做什么的故事。我们已经进入节目的第二幕。
Act Two, Synchronized Swimmers. So in the ocean, when you get off course, there are all kinds of dangers that you face that just are not there when you're on dry land. Phoebe Judge has a story where you see some of that. She's the host of the This Is Love podcast, where a version of this story first ran.
第二幕，花样游泳运动员。在海洋中，当你偏离航线时，你会面临各种在陆地上不存在的危险。菲比·贾奇有一个故事，你可以从中看到一些。她是《这就是爱》播客的主持人，这个故事的一个版本最早就在那里播出。
When Lynne Cox was a teenager, she was a competitive long-distance ocean swimmer. Six days a week, she'd wake up early to swim at a beach near her house in Southern California. Typically, she'd swim back and forth in the deep water between a really long pier and a stone jetty. She was training for a 21-mile swim.
琳恩·考克斯十几岁时，是一名竞技远程海洋游泳运动员。每周六天，她会早起去南加州家附近的海滩游泳。通常，她会在一个很长的码头和一个石堤之间的深水区来回游。她当时正在为一场21英里的游泳做准备。
It was March, and I was 17 years old, and I was going for a morning swim. It was before the sun had risen, and the water was pitch black. I started swimming between the Seal Beach Pier and the jetty. And so my plan was just to go in and stretch out and swim for an hour and be done and then go hang out with my high school friends. But I started swimming, and as I got closer to the pier, I felt the water hollowing out around me, meaning that I could feel something underneath pulling me forward.
那是三月，我17岁，去进行晨泳。太阳还没升起，水里漆黑一片。我开始在海豹滩码头和防波堤之间游泳。我的计划只是进去拉伸一下，游一个小时，然后结束，再去跟高中朋友闲逛。但我开始游了，当我靠近码头时，我感觉到周围的水在凹陷，这意味着我能感觉到下面有什么东西在推着我向前。
It felt like something really big was swimming below. And so in my mind, I'm thinking, oh my gosh. Is it a seal? And I'm like, no, it's too big for a seal. And it's like, OK, is it a dolphin? No, it's not a dolphin. And then I thought, oh my god. Could it be a shark? What is this below me?
感觉好像有个很大的东西在下面游动。我心里想，哦天哪。是海豹吗？我心想，不，对海豹来说太大了。然后我心想，好吧，是海豚吗？不，不是海豚。然后我想，哦天哪。可能是鲨鱼吗？我下面是什么？
I mean, this is most people's biggest nightmare on Earth, that they would be swimming in the water, and that they would feel something large underneath them.
我是说，这是地球上大多数人最大的噩梦，在水里游泳时，感觉到下面有巨大的东西。
And I think that that's normal, to be scared. I mean, when you can't see anything below, but you can feel something, and you can also not just feel the motion but the presence of something. But when you do these long swims, you have to keep your mind under control because if you freak out, then you're out of a swim. So I kept talking to myself and saying, OK, you're not sure what it is. Just move closer to shore. So I swam closer to shore, but this thing kept swimming around near me. The water kept getting hollowed out.
我觉得感到害怕很正常。当你看不到下面有什么，但能感觉到，而且不仅能感受到运动，还能感受到某种存在。但当你进行这些长距离游泳时，你必须控制住你的思想，因为如果你惊慌失措，你就没法游了。所以我一直对自己说话，说，好吧，你不确定那是什么。向岸边靠拢。所以我游向岸边，但那个东西一直在附近游动。水一直不停地凹陷。
And I realized that whatever was there was still there, and it had not gone away. And I was just ready to turn and race out of the water. But there was an old man named Steve who worked in the bait shop on the pier, and he sort of watched over me and watched what was going on with the water. And I could see him standing under a light on the pier, waving toward me to come, to swim out to him. And he yelled at me and said, Lynne, come here. There's a baby whale swimming with you.
我意识到无论那是什么，它都还在那儿，而且并没有离开。我已经准备好转身冲出水面了。但码头上有一个叫史蒂夫的老人，他在码头的诱饵店工作，他有点像是在看护我，观察着水里的动静。我能看到他站在码头的一盏灯下，挥手示意我游过去。他对我喊道：琳恩，过来。有一头小鲸鱼在跟你一起游。
So you stick your head out of the water, and he's waving, and he says, there's a baby whale?
所以你把头探出水面，他在挥手，说有一头小鲸鱼？
Yeah. He said a baby whale, and I'm like, really? I have never seen a baby whale in the wild before. So he told me that the baby whale had lost his mother, and I needed to stay with the baby whale.
是的。他说小鲸鱼，我心想，真的吗？我以前从未在野外见过小鲸鱼。所以他告诉我，小鲸鱼跟妈妈走散了，我需要陪着这头小鲸鱼。
Why did you need to stay with the baby whale? Why couldn't you get out?
你为什么要陪着小鲸鱼？为什么不能出来？
He was afraid that if I turned to go to shore that the baby whale would follow me and possibly could run aground, but he also thought that maybe the baby whale will just swim off and be totally lost. So his idea was that you just need to stay with the baby whale.
他担心如果我转身去岸边，小鲸鱼会跟着我，可能会搁浅，但他还认为也许小鲸鱼会游走，然后彻底迷路。所以他的主意是，你只需要陪着小鲸鱼。
It can be dangerous for baby whales to be separated from their mothers. There are predators around, like sharks, and also, young whales are totally dependent on their mother's milk to survive. A while back, there was a story about a baby whale getting so lost it tried to suckle on a yacht.
小鲸鱼跟妈妈走散可能很危险。周围有鲨鱼这样的捕食者，而且幼鲸完全依赖母亲的乳汁生存。前段时间，有一个故事说一头小鲸鱼迷路到试图吮吸游艇。
That sense of being lost was something I related to with the baby whale.
那种迷失的感觉是我能与小鲸鱼产生共鸣的。
Is it easy as a swimmer to get off course?
游泳者容易偏离路线吗？
Yeah. And I think the thing that most people don't know about when you're in the ocean-- if you get lost, and you try to continue going, you start swimming in a huge circle. And that makes it more difficult for anyone to find you. And so the mother may not find the baby ever.
是的。我想大多数人在海里不知道的是——如果你迷路了，试图继续前进，你就会开始绕一个巨大的圈游。这让任何人找到你都变得更困难。所以妈妈可能永远找不到宝宝。
At this point, Lynne still couldn't see the baby whale beneath her in the water. She only saw bits and pieces of it swimming.
此时，琳恩仍然看不到水下的幼鲸。她只能看到它游动时露出的局部。
You could only see part of him. I mean, you couldn't see his whole head or face. You just saw his back. And the baby gray whale then surfaced, and he swam over toward me. It was scary. It was scary because he was so big, and I was not sure how to deal with him. I mean, how do I interact with a whale?
你只能看到它的一部分。我的意思是，你看不到它的整个头或脸。你只能看到它的背。然后那头灰鲸幼崽浮出水面，游向我。那很吓人。很吓人，因为它太大了，我不确定怎么处理它。我是说，我怎么跟鲸鱼互动？
Steve, though, was so calm and assured that it was just fine to be in the water with a baby that I thought, well, he knows. He's this old guy that's been out here forever, and so he knows everything about the ocean. So I will do what he told me to do is, and then I'll just stay out here with this whale until we find his mother.
不过史蒂夫非常冷静，而且很肯定跟一只小鲸鱼待在水里完全没事，所以我想，好吧，他懂。他是这个一直待在这里的老人家，所以他了解关于海洋的一切。所以我照他说的做，我就待在这里陪这头鲸鱼，直到找到它的妈妈。
Steve got on the radio to all the fishing boat captains and lifeguards along the coast and told them to keep their eyes out for a large gray whale traveling north. He told Lynne to swim back towards the jetty. Once she got to the jetty, she turned around and swam back to the pier again. The baby stayed with her.
史蒂夫用无线电联系了沿海所有的渔船船长和救生员，告诉他们留意一头向北航行的大灰鲸。他让琳恩游回防波堤。一旦她到达防波堤，她就转身游回码头。幼鲸一直跟着她。
We were sort of side by side, or he was right underneath me or very, very close. And at one point, he just rolled over and looked right at me. And it was just the most amazing thing in the world because I felt like he sees me and I see him, and we're together.
我们算是并排游，或者它就在我正下方，非常、非常近。有一次，它只是翻了个身，直直地看着我。那简直是世界上最神奇的事情，因为我感觉它看到了我，我也看到了它，我们在一起。
How big is a baby gray whale's eye?
灰鲸幼崽的眼睛有多大？
It was sort of the size, I'd say, of a plum or a orange. It's large. And it was dark, dark, dark brown, almost black.
大概有李子或橙子那么大吧。很大。它是深、深、深棕色的，几乎是黑色的。
Did you try to talk to him? Were you talking to him?
你试着跟它说话了吗？你在跟它说话吗？
Yes. [LAUGHS] Yes, yes. I mean, I was like-- as if he would understand-- but I told him he'd be OK and that things will work out, and we'll find his mother. And I'm thinking, oh my gosh. He can't understand my words, but maybe he'll understand the feeling or the intention.
是的。[笑声]是的，是的。我是说，我当时就像——好像它能听懂似的——但我告诉它，你会没事的，事情会解决的，我们会找到你妈妈。我心想，哦天哪。它听不懂我的话，但也许它能听懂那种感觉或意图。
They swam for an hour, then another hour. Lynne started to wonder if it was even possible for the mother to find the baby. How do you find something in the ocean? She got scared that the mother might never be coming. She got scared that the mother could be dead. Maybe the mother was dead.
他们游了一个小时，又一个小时。琳恩开始怀疑妈妈是否还能找到宝宝。你怎么在海里找东西？她害怕妈妈可能永远不会来了。她害怕妈妈可能死了。也许妈妈死了。
Some people had gathered on the pier with Steve to watch what was going on, and the fishermen out in boats were all talking to each other on the radio. One of them reported seeing a large gray whale swimming near an oil rig about a mile and a half offshore. And then, as though the baby whale was listening to the radio, it abruptly turned and started swimming in the direction of the oil rig. Normally, Lynne wouldn't swim out into the open ocean without a boat or somebody near her, but she decided to follow.
一些人跟史蒂夫一起聚在码头上观察着，海上的渔民们都在无线电里互相交谈。其中一个人报告说，看到一头大灰鲸在离岸约一英里半的石油钻井平台附近游动。然后，就像小鲸鱼听到了无线电一样，它突然转向，开始朝着石油钻井平台的方向游去。通常情况下，琳恩不会在没有船或附近没人的情况下游到公海，但她决定跟着。
He made a point of swimming right in front of me and a little bit below so I could swim in his slipstream. And I thought, wow, I bet he learned that from his mother. I bet when they were migrating north, he was in her slipstream, and it enabled him to swim much easier than against the strong currents. And it was just so cool. I mean, because I was hardly moving at all, my arms, and I was just flying through the water.
它特意游在我正前方稍微下方一点，这样我就可以在它的尾流里游。我想，哇，我敢打赌它是从妈妈那儿学来的。我敢打赌当它们向北迁徙时，它就在妈妈的尾流里，这让它比逆着强流游要轻松得多。那真是太酷了。我是说，因为我几乎没怎么动胳膊，我就像在水里飞一样。
And I just thought, wow, can he-- you know, at times, I tried to think about, how does he see me? And he must have thought, horrible swimmer, she is. [LAUGHS] He's just so beautiful, elegant, graceful in the water and just moves so effortlessly. Just one big kick of his fin, his tail fin, his fluke, and he would just move, and here I was struggling with my arms. He probably thought I needed help.
我只是想，哇，它能——你知道，有时，我试图思考，它是怎么看我的？它一定在想，她真是个糟糕的游泳者。[笑声]它在水里是如此美丽、优雅、从容，移动得如此轻松。它的鳍、尾鳍或侧鳍只要轻轻一拨，它就能移动，而我在这里挣扎着挥动胳膊。它可能觉得我需要帮助。
By this time, Lynne had been in the water with the whale for almost four hours. As strong a swimmer as Lynne was, she didn't know how much longer she could be in that cold water. They swam towards the oil rig for a while but didn't see the other whale, and Lynne realized she'd have to make a decision soon.
此时，琳恩和鲸鱼已经在水里待了近四个小时。尽管琳恩是个强壮的游泳者，但她不知道自己还能在冷水里待多久。它们向石油钻井平台游了一阵，但没看到另一头鲸鱼，琳恩意识到她很快就得做出决定。
I was used to swimming very long distances. But there were points along the way where I was getting tired and cold because I was not swimming at my normal speed. I was treading water. I was wondering where the whale was going because he was suddenly diving down deep into the water. And I think it was about four and a half hours or five hours into this time out there in the water I was getting really cold, and I realized that I was putting myself in danger now, that I could go into hypothermia. And if I got hypothermia, then I could become really disoriented, and I could also pass out in the water. It was five hours of swimming around and not really going anywhere. So I decided that I really needed to start getting back toward the pier.
我习惯了长距离游泳。但路上有一些时候，我感到疲倦和寒冷，因为我没按平时的速度游。我在踩水。我当时在想鲸鱼要去哪儿，因为它突然向深水区潜下去。我觉得大概是在水里待了四个半到五个小时后，我真的很冷，我意识到自己现在处于危险之中，我可能会体温过低。如果我体温过低，我可能会变得非常神志不清，还可能在水里昏过去。那是我游了五个小时，却没真的去哪儿。所以我决定我真的需要开始往回游向码头。
She turned around and swam back toward the pier. The whale stayed with her. Then Lynne saw a Long Beach lifeguard boat coming towards her at full speed. And when it reached her, a lifeguard told her she was out too far, but then he told her something else. A commercial fishing boat had spotted a solo whale only a half mile from the pier, where Lynne usually swam, and that the whale was now swimming in their direction.
她转身游回码头。鲸鱼一直跟着她。然后琳恩看到一艘长滩救生员船全速向她开来。当船靠近她时，一名救生员告诉她她游得太远了，但随后他又告诉了她另一件事。一艘商业渔船在离码头——琳恩通常游泳的地方——仅半英里处发现了一头独自游动的鲸鱼，而且那头鲸鱼现在正朝着她们的方向游来。
I kept thinking, oh my god, please let him somehow hear her. Hopefully she's making some kind of noise so that he can understand that she's approaching, or maybe he's doing something that she's hearing, the cry of the baby to come and find him.
我一直想，哦天哪，请一定要让它听到它。希望它能发出某种声音，好让它明白妈妈正在靠近，或者也许它在做什么，妈妈能听到宝宝的呼唤来找到它。
Even though this is what she'd been hoping for, Lynne didn't quite know what to do. Full-size gray whales can be 50 feet long and weigh 90,000 pounds.
尽管这正是她一直希望的，琳恩却不知道该怎么办。成年灰鲸可以长达50英尺，体重达90,000磅。
Oh, I would have gotten so-- I would have been-- I would have gotten so-- did you get nervous about this mother coming?
哦，我会变得非常——我会——你会因为妈妈要来而感到紧张吗？
I was really nervous because, again, it was like, do I stay in the water? Do I get out of the water? Do I stay with the baby? What do I do? And so I thought, well, my intention all along has been good, and the baby recognizes that. And so hopefully they're communicating, and she will understand that this has been a good thing.
我真的很紧张，因为再次，我在想，我是待在水里还是出来？我待在宝宝身边吗？我该怎么办？所以我心想，嗯，我一直以来的意图都是好的，宝宝也认同这一点。所以希望它们在沟通，她会明白这已经是一件好事了。
And what happened?
后来呢？
When she actually swam over to us, she came over very, very slowly and didn't come really close to me initially. But a few minutes later, she came right next to me. And when a mother whale comes next to you, it's like a bus pulling up beside you. And I backed away some because I was afraid. I mean, the animal is 40 feet long, 45 feet long, and to be in the water with something so huge is frightening.
当她真的游过来时，她游得非常、非常慢，起初并没有离我特别近。但几分钟后，她就到了我旁边。当一头母鲸来到你身边时，就像一辆公交车停在你旁边。我退后了一些，因为我害怕。我是说，动物长40到45英尺，跟如此巨大的东西待在水里很吓人。
I mean, because just one push of her fin or anything, I could be hurt. So I tried to tell myself, just be calm. Just float on the water, and if she doesn't want you around, you will know that very quickly. So I saw them together, and it was one of the most beautiful things I've ever seen in my life, to see the mother and baby reunited. I mean, for five hours, we'd been out there swimming together.
我是说，因为它鳍的轻轻一推，我就可能受伤。所以我试着告诉自己，冷静。只要漂在水面上，如果她不想要你在附近，你很快就会知道。所以我看到它们在一起，那是我一生中见过的最美丽的事情之一，看到母子团聚。我是说，五个小时了，我们一直在外面一起游泳。
And she came over. She approached me. And so she was so close that I thought, I'm going to touch her. I'm just going to do it because I feel like a part of this whole thing. And I touched her, and I could feel that she felt my hand on her. And it was amazing because she was so big. And then a few minutes later, they swam off.
然后她过来了。她靠近了我。她离得那么近，以至于我心想，我要摸摸她。我一定要这么做，因为我觉得自己也是这一切的一部分。我摸了她，我能感觉到她感觉到了我放在她身上的手。这太神奇了，因为她太大了。几分钟后，它们游走了。
While Lynne swam back to the shore, the lifeguard made sure that the cargo ships around Los Angeles Harbor knew where the mother and baby were swimming. Later, boats reported seeing the two join a group of whales on their way north. When she got back to the beach, Lynne asked a lifeguard if she could use the phone to call her parents to let them know that her workout had gone longer than she expected, and she was on her way home.
当琳恩游回岸上时，救生员确保了洛杉矶港周围的货船知道母子俩在哪里游动。后来，船只报告说看到它们俩加入了一群向北航行的鲸群。回到海滩时，琳恩问救生员是否可以用电话给父母打个电话，告诉他们她的运动比预期的时间长了一些，她正在回家的路上。
And it was so weird, though, to go from-- that's always so weird, to be in this amazing environment, the ocean, to then leave it and then go back to, OK, now what am I doing the rest of the day? It's just so strange. But I didn't tell my parents what had happened because I knew I would have been in so much trouble, because it was so irresponsible for me to swim offshore without support, without people watching the water. But I told myself it was really OK because Steve was out there watching, and the lifeguards were out there watching, and they knew what was going on. But it was still a stretch. I think now that what I did was pretty dumb, but if I was to do it again, I'd still do it because I felt like it was something I could do.
不过，从——那种感觉总是很奇怪，置身于令人惊叹的环境中，也就是海洋，然后离开它，回到现实，好吧，我这一天剩下时间做什么？那太奇怪了。但我没告诉父母发生了什么，因为我知道我会惹上大麻烦，因为我不带后援、不让别人看护就在离岸的地方游泳太不负责任了。但我告诉自己，这确实没关系，因为史蒂夫在看护，救生员也在看护，他们知道发生了什么。但那仍然有点过头。我现在想，我当时做的事情很蠢，但如果再来一次，我还是会做，因为我觉得这是我能做到的事情。
A few weeks later, Lynne found herself off course in the ocean. She was trying to set a record, become the fastest person to swim the Catalina Channel, that 21-mile stretch off the coast of California. Lynne set out at midnight with a support boat-- a dory-- and a coach on a paddle board beside her.
几周后，琳恩发现自己在海里偏离了路线。她试图创造纪录，成为游过卡塔琳娜海峡——离加州海岸21英里的路段——速度最快的人。琳恩在午夜出发，带了一艘补给船——小艇——旁边还有一个教练在浆板上陪着她。
On that attempt from Catalina Island, the fog came in at midnight. I got separated from my support boat, the dory, and I just had a coach on a paddle board, so we were lost in the middle of the channel at midnight. And there were ships surrounding us, and we were feeling the bow waves breaking. To be lost in the fog where you can't see more than 10 meters in front of you in the pitch blackness, and to feel and to hear ships moving around you, is absolutely terrifying. And my coach, who had had no experience in the open water, had told me to just keep swimming because eventually the crew would find us.
在从卡塔琳娜岛的那次尝试中，午夜起了雾。我和我的补给船小艇分开了，我身边只有一个在浆板上的教练，所以我们在午夜时分在海峡中间迷路了。周围都是船，我们能感觉到船首波在破碎。在伸手不见五指、前方视线不超过10米的迷雾中迷路，感觉到并听到周围船只在移动，真是绝对恐怖。我的教练在公海毫无经验，他告诉我继续游，因为最终船员会找到我们。
But then Lynne thought of the baby whale. The way the whale, even though it lived in the water, had lost its way and ended up further and further from its mother. Lynne didn't want this to happen to her, so she stopped swimming and gave up her attempt at the record. She says she and her coach just stayed put, bobbing up and down in the water until eventually her crew picked them up.
但琳恩想到了那头小鲸鱼。鲸鱼尽管生活在水里，却迷失了方向，离母亲越来越远。琳恩不想这种情况发生在自己身上，所以她停止了游泳，放弃了打破纪录的尝试。她说她和教练只是待在原地，在水里上下浮动，直到最终她的船员把他们接上了船。
Phoebe Judge. A version of this story was on her podcast, This Is Love, from Criminal and Vox Media. Lynne Cox, who she interviewed, twice won the record for the fastest crossing of the English Channel. She was also the very first person to swim across the Bering Strait from the United States to the Soviet Union. Just for the record, by the way, it can be illegal to touch a whale. So, you know, don't try this at home.
菲比·贾奇。这个故事的一个版本曾出现在她的播客《这就是爱》上，来自Criminal和Vox Media。琳恩·考克斯，她采访的人，曾两次获得横渡英吉利海峡最快纪录。她也是历史上第一个从美国游到苏联横渡白令海峡的人。顺便提一下，触碰鲸鱼可能是违法的。所以，你知道，不要在家里尝试这个。
Act Three, The Year of Manic-al Thinking. So we now turn to another father and daughter who get abruptly thrown off the path they thought they were on, shoved off course. And in this case, we see the strange places that takes them to. Casey Wilson is a comedian. She tells the story. It begins when she's 24 years old, and her mom dies suddenly.
第三幕，疯狂思考的一年。现在我们要转到另一对父女身上，他们突然偏离了他们以为自己所处的道路，被挤出了轨道。在这种情况下，我们看到了这把他们带去了奇怪的地方。凯西·威尔逊是一位喜剧演员。她讲述了这个故事。故事开始于她24岁时，她的母亲突然去世。
It happened on a family trip to Rehoboth Beach, Delaware. My parents got there a day before my brother and me and had a nice married couple's evening. Bought a Tom Clancy novel for my dad, took a walk on the beach holding hands, fell asleep watching Sex and the City. The next morning, my dad got up earlier than my mom.
那发生在特拉华州里霍博斯海滩的一次家庭旅行中。我父母比我和我弟弟早到了一天，度过了一个美好的夫妻之夜。给我爸爸买了一本汤姆·克兰西的小说，手牵手在海滩上散步，看《欲望都市》睡着了。第二天早上，我爸爸比我妈妈起得早。
And so I went to breakfast and gathered up all the papers for her, and then I came back to the room. And lo and behold, I got just the shock of a lifetime as I realized that she wasn't doing very well at all. I mean, that's to say the least. She had turned black and blue in the two hours I had gone and left, and she had clearly died in that period of time from a heart attack.
于是我去吃早餐，帮她整理好所有的报纸，然后我回到房间。没想到，我受到了这一生中最大的震惊，因为我意识到她的情况非常糟糕。我是说，这只是轻描淡写。在我离开的那两个小时里，她全身变得青紫，很明显她在那个时间段内死于心脏病发作。
My dad, Paul, can be a little detached when he talks about this. And it's not just that it's a tough thing for anyone to talk about. He has a really hard time talking about his feelings. But he's expressive in so many other ways. To be clear, he's a great dad. When I was eight, he built this stage for me in the backyard to put on plays and during the finale set off fireworks in the garden. He was my Girl Scout leader till I was 17. He's got a big personality. He's happy-go-lucky, generous. Makes political ads for a living, so he has friends all over the country. People call him the unofficial mayor of our neighborhood.
我爸爸保罗谈论这件事时会有点抽离。这不仅仅是因为这对任何人来说都是一件沉重的事情。他很难谈论自己的感受。但他以许多其他方式表达情感。明确一点，他是个好爸爸。我八岁时，他在后院为我搭了一个舞台演戏，在结尾时在花园里放了烟火。他一直担任我的女童军领队到我17岁。他个性鲜明。他随和、慷慨。他靠制作政治广告谋生，所以他在全国各地都有朋友。人们称他为我们社区的非官方市长。
And my mom, Kathy, was an equally big personality. She fought for the Equal Rights Amendment, was the youngest chairwoman of the National Women's Political Caucus. She was an incredibly passionate person, the type who could go from anger to laughter in the same sentence, extremely funny, and, really, just fun. But the thing she'd say before anything we did was, let's have a big old time. And so for her to just be gone so suddenly-- she was only 54-- even my dad, who has a hard time expressing feelings, the word he uses is brutal.
我妈妈凯茜个性同样鲜明。她争取《平等权利修正案》，是全国妇女政治核心小组最年轻的主席。她是一个极其充满激情的人，那种能在一句话里从愤怒切换到欢笑的人，极其风趣，而且，真的，很有趣。但她在做任何事情前都会说的一句话是：让我们玩得尽兴。所以她就这么突然走了——她才54岁——即使是我爸爸，那个很难表达感受的人，用的词也是：残酷。
It was absolutely, instantly paralyzing, instantly frightening, and disorienting.
那完全、瞬间让我瘫痪，瞬间令人恐惧和迷惑。
In a state of shock, my dad did something really strange, something I've never heard of anyone doing.
处于震惊状态中，我爸爸做了一些非常奇怪的事情，一些我从未听说过有人会做的事情。
Well, I remember that back in the day, we had film. And so I noticed that I had a few images left on the roll.
嗯，我记得当时，我们还有胶卷。所以我注意到胶卷里还剩下几张照片的位置。
This was 2005.
那是2005年。
And I was alone with your mom, and I decided to capture the moment with a few stills. What I didn't realize is how gruesome it really did look, that when life is gone, it is gone.
我当时和你妈妈单独在一起，我决定用几张静止照片捕捉那一刻。我没意识到拍出来看起来有多么恐怖，当生命消逝，就是消逝了。
And, Dad, why was your instinct in that moment to take photos of Mom?
而且，爸爸，你在那一刻的本能为什么是拍妈妈的照片？
Well, I just felt like we might want this. Now, it turned out we didn't want it, but we went ahead and have it.
嗯，我只是觉得我们可能会想要这个。结果，我们并不想要，但我们还是拍了。
I found these photos by accident. I was home about a year after she died and flipping through rolls and rolls of photos my dad took, and intermingled between pictures of his softball team were about a dozen photos of my mom, dead. And one was a selfie. I threw them on the ground and just remember screaming and crying and my dad saying, oops. Forgot those were on that roll. I thought, who would do this? Take a selfie with a dead body?
我是无意中发现这些照片的。她去世一年后我在家，翻看我爸爸拍的一卷卷照片，在拍摄他垒球队的照片中间大约有十几张我妈妈死亡的照片。其中一张是自拍。我把照片扔在地上，记得在大声尖叫和哭泣，我爸爸说：哎呀。忘了那卷胶卷上有这些了。我想，谁会这么做？跟一具尸体自拍？
And then how do you forget you have these photos and just leave them out for your kids to find? I mean, I was equally unmoored by my mom's death. I moved a mattress into my closet. I set up a shrine to my mom around me and spent hours crying in the darkness of that strange cave. But my dad dealt with it very differently. He made choices I've never understood, and we've never spoken about it. Talking for this story is the first conversation we've ever had about that time.
而且你怎会忘了你有这些照片，还随便丢在孩子们能找到的地方？我是说，我也因为妈妈的去世而同样心乱如麻。我把床垫搬进了衣柜。我把妈妈的照片放在周围设立了祭坛，在那个奇怪的洞穴般的黑暗里待了几个小时哭泣。但我爸爸的处理方式截然不同。他做出的选择是我从未理解过的，我们从来没谈论过。为了这个故事进行对话，是我们第一次谈论那个时期。
Let's start with the funeral. My dad became obsessed with the idea that we were not only going to want it filmed, but filmed right. So he hired a crew to do it as a three-camera shoot, like a TV sitcom, to make into a DVD that he'd give out as stocking stuffers. Just what everyone wants for Christmas. To give you a sense of how hardcore my dad was about all this, when I gave my eulogy, the sound cut out during the last five minutes. So he insisted on bringing me into the sound booth at his office to do ADR, which in TV and film is when you rerecord any dialogue that got messed up. I work as an actress, and I've done this many times. But to be directed by my father saying goodbye to my mom was surreal.
让我们从葬礼开始。我爸爸沉迷于一个想法，不仅要录像，而且要拍好。所以他雇了一个团队进行了三机位拍摄，就像电视情景喜剧一样，做成DVD当圣诞礼物送人。这正是大家圣诞节想要的。为了让你知道我爸爸在这方面有多硬核，我在致悼词时，最后五分钟声音断了。所以他坚持带我到他办公室的录音室去做ADR，在电视和电影中，这就是重新录制任何弄坏的对话。我是个演员，我做过很多次。但被我父亲指导着向我妈妈告别简直是超现实的。
And so I had you rerecord. And so I pushed you a little bit, and you weren't into it. It was very low energy. And I said, come on, Casey. You've got to do this with a little more enthusiasm, a little more oomph.
所以我让你重新录制。我推了你一把，你不太想做。当时能量非常低。我说：来吧，凯西。你必须带着更多热情，更多冲劲来做这件事。
A little more oomph. You wanted me to be-- you wanted me to feel it more.
更多冲劲。你想让我——你想让我感受得更多。
Yeah.
是的。
And, quote, "really go there."
而且，引用你的话，“真正投入进去”。
And to cry.
还要哭出来。
And to cry, yeah.
还要哭出来，是的。
So I had you do it with a little more oomph, and we finally got a good take.
所以我让你带着更多冲劲再做一遍，我们终于得到了一个好镜头。
But why did it feel so important to you at the time?
但为什么这在那时让你觉得如此重要？
That's a good question. It just felt like that was an act of completion, and we needed it. We needed it done.
这是个好问题。只是感觉那是一种完结的举动，我们需要它。我们需要做完这件事。
The final product did drop by Christmas. It was a three-and-a-half-hour two-parter that, I'm guessing, not one person watched. Next, my dad decided to, quote, "take the funeral on the road," meaning he set up six additional funerals in different cities across the country for his friends. If the funeral in our hometown was the Broadway show, my dad embarked on the national tour. He booked hotel conference rooms, brought along a life-size photo of my mom, and redelivered his own eulogy. At some of these, there were 60 or 70 people.
成品赶在圣诞节前送出了。那是一个三个半小时的两集片，我猜，没一个人看完。接下来，我爸爸决定“把葬礼带上路”，意思是他在全国不同城市为他的朋友又举办了六场额外的葬礼。如果说我们家乡的那场葬礼是百老汇演出，我爸爸开启了全国巡演。他预订了酒店会议室，带上一张我妈妈等身大的照片，并重新发表了他的悼词。有些场次有60或70人。
At the time, I could not understand why he would put himself through this again and again. The way I saw it back then, based on his daily updates, these felt less like funerals and more like huge parties for him. I mean, a lot of these people never even met my mom, which left me wondering, what was the point?
当时，我无法理解他为什么要一遍又一遍地让自己经历这些。按照我当时基于他每日更新的观察，这些看起来不像是葬礼，更像是他举办的大型派对。我是说，这些人很多根本没见过我妈妈，这让我好奇，意义何在？
I wanted her, meaning your mom, I wanted her to feel like we had really loved her and really cherished her.
我想要她，意思是你的妈妈，我想要她觉得我们真的爱她、真的珍惜她。
Yeah. Did you think at the time you felt more like, I'm doing this as sort something to keep busy or drive towards or do instead of maybe, like, feeling?
是的。你当时觉得你这样做更多是为了保持忙碌，或是为了去做点什么来替代感受？
To me, this was healing. This was how I healed.
对我来说，这是治愈。这就是我治愈的方式。
Weeks after my dad got back from the funeral tour, just three months after my mom died, I got a phone call from him I never would have imagined I'd get so soon. I was driving in LA, where I live, and he told me he was going to start dating again. Then he amended that and said he had actually already started dating again. I found it unthinkable. How could he possibly be ready to date? It felt so dishonoring of my mom. I've never understood it and never asked why he started dating so soon till we had this conversation. The way he tells it, it's like it happened to him. This was not what I expected.
我爸爸葬礼巡演回来几周后，就在妈妈去世才三个月，我接到了一个做梦都想不到他会这么快打来的电话。我在洛杉矶开车时，他告诉我他要开始再次约会了。然后他更正说，他实际上已经开始再次约会了。我觉得这不可思议。他怎么可能准备好约会？这感觉是对妈妈的不敬。我从未理解这一点，也从未问过为什么他开始得这么快，直到我们进行了这次对话。按照他的叙述，这就像是这件事发生在他身上。这不是我预料到的。
So I'm at the bar, and I had my back to the windows. And all of a sudden, I hear pounding on the window. And I turn around, and it's somebody I don't know, and they are motioning for me to go outside. I go outside, and they instantly start kissing me. Don't ask me why.
所以我在酒吧里，背对着窗户。突然，我听到窗户上有敲击声。我转过身，是一个我不认识的人，她在示意我到外面去。我走出去，她们立即开始吻我。别问我为什么。
What?
什么？
Yeah. Maybe they had had a little too much to drink.
是的。也许她们喝得太多了。
Wait. Wait a minute. This is harassment.
等等。等一下。这是骚扰。
Yes. Just out of the blue. And I go, whoa--
是的。突然就这样了。我说：哇——
You're telling me a woman kissed you from seeing you in a window?
你是说一个女人因为在窗外看到你就吻了你？
Yeah, through the window. Yes.
是的，透过窗户。是的。
This woman was a complete stranger and, to my eye, a predator. But to my dad, this felt like a meet-cute in When Harry Met Sally. And not long after that, the floodgates opened. He started dating everyone. My mom's good friends, Mom's first cousin, a C-SPAN anchor, everyone. He literally-- he asked a woman out he met in a crosswalk. When I think of my dad at this time, it's like he was a blurry image. He just never stopped moving.
这个女人是个完全的陌生人，在我看来是个掠夺者。但对我爸爸，这感觉像是《当哈利遇上莎莉》里的美丽邂逅。没过多久，闸门大开。他开始和所有人约会。我妈妈的好友、妈妈的表亲、C-SPAN的主播，所有人。他甚至——他约了一个他在人行横道上遇到的女人。当我想起那时候的爸爸，他就像一张模糊的图像。他从来没停下来过。
Some people say that the first year after a loved one dies is the worst, but for him, as he entered year two, things ramped up even more. He was acting manic. He'd call every day with these new, grandiose ideas and big plans that no one could talk him out of. At one point, he attempted to wallpaper our living room with wrapping paper because, as he told me, why pay all that money for wallpaper when wrapping paper at the Paper Source is just as nice? He bought a woman in our church new teeth. And then there was his hair.
有人说亲人去世后的第一年是最糟糕的，但对他来说，进入第二年，事情升级得更多。他的行为很狂躁。他每天打电话过来，说着没人能劝阻的宏大构想和大型计划。有一次，他试图用包装纸糊客厅的墙，因为正如他告诉我的：为什么花那么多钱买壁纸，而Paper Source的包装纸也一样好？他给教会里的一个女人买了新牙齿。然后就是他的头发。
So I walked into the woman who'd been cutting my hair, and she was a senior expert. And I walked in, and I said, I want to do something different, and I pulled out a $20 bill. And I held it up to her, and I said, I want to look like this. And it's Andrew Jackson, and he has long waves of hair that go back across his ear and to the back of his head. And I go, that's how I want to look.
所以我走进那个一直给我剪发的女人的店，她是资深专家。我走进去说：我想做点不一样的。我掏出一张20美元钞票。我举起来对她说：我想看起来像这样。那是安德鲁·杰克逊，他有向后延伸过耳朵一直到脑后的长波浪头发。我说：我就想看起来那样。
This senior expert gave him a large barrel perm. He texted me a picture of himself in curlers. It is a shock I have never gotten over and one I hope no one else has to go through. Then, he had a run-in with the law. One night at a restaurant, he picked a fight with a maitre d' on behalf of an older woman who was not being seated, and the cops were called. And as they were dragging him out, my dad, who hadn't eaten yet, managed to rally the whole bar into throwing nuts into his mouth, shouting, "Nut me!" as he passed.
这位资深专家给了他一个大卷烫发。他给我发了一张自己戴着卷发器的照片。那是让我至今无法释怀的震惊，也是我希望没别人需要经历的震惊。然后，他触犯了法律。有一天晚上在餐厅，他因为一位老妇人没被安排入座，跟领班大吵一架，警察来了。当他们把他拖出去时，还没吃饭的爸爸成功鼓动整个酒吧的人把坚果扔进他嘴里，边通过边喊：“给我坚果！”
He called me later that night laughing, just thinking I would get such a kick out of the story and his great comedic exit line. And he was shocked by how concerned I was. Now, just to say, my dad was seeing a grief therapist at the time. And, unbeknownst to me, she helped explain what was happening to him. The sudden loss of his wife had triggered some manic behavior. It was a reaction to grief she'd seen before. There's actually a term for this, "bereavement mania," manic behavior caused by the stress of losing a loved one.
那天晚上晚些时候他打电话给我，笑得很开心，以为我会从这个故事和他的绝妙喜剧谢幕语中得到很大的乐趣。但他对我表现出的担忧感到震惊。现在，说明一下，我爸爸当时正在看悲伤治疗师。而且，我不知道，她帮我解释了发生在他身上的事情。妻子的突然离世触发了一些狂躁行为。这是她以前见过的一种对悲伤的反应。这实际上有个术语，叫“丧亲狂躁”，因失去亲人压力导致的狂躁行为。
And this kind of mania can happen in people with no other history of mood disorders, and it can happen just once and not recur. But at the time, I didn't know any of that. And so I was just horrified by the things he was doing and the places he was showing up. Our neighbors across the street told him, Paul, come by any time, whatever you need, the way people do when someone dies. And he sure did. He showed up unannounced in their hot tub more than once. I told him, Dad, no one wants you in their hot tub every night. These are hard words you're making me say to you, but you're giving me no choice.
这种狂躁在那些没有其他情绪障碍史的人身上也会发生，可能只发生一次而不再复发。但当时，我不知道这一切。所以我对他做的事情和他出现的地方感到震惊。街对面的邻居告诉他：保罗，随时过来，无论你需要什么，这是人们在有人去世时常说的。他也确实这样做了。他不止一次不请自来地出现在他们的热水浴缸里。我告诉他：爸爸，没人希望你每天晚上在他们的浴缸里。这些是我被迫对你说的重话，但你没给我选择。
Or there was the time someone stole his car, and he tried to set up a sting to get it back. I was so worried about him, I tried to get him to come stay with me so I could keep an eye on him. And when these tactics failed, I threw fits, and I cried. And he would actually yell, stop trying to control me! I'm fine! He kept trying to explain he was OK and that, in fact, he was having fun. Sometimes I'd felt like I'd lost my mom and my dad. And then, it all came to a head at a wedding.
还有一次有人偷了他的车，他试图设局把它拿回来。我太担心他了，试图让他过来和我住，这样我可以盯着他。当这些战术失败时，我会发脾气，我会哭。他竟然大喊：别再试图控制我！我很好！他一直试图解释他很好，事实上，他玩得很开心。有时我觉得我失去了妈妈，也失去了爸爸。然后，这一切在一次婚礼上达到了顶点。
Can we talk about Amanda's wedding?
我们能谈谈阿曼达的婚礼吗？
Yeah, but I don't think it's really relevant here. Do you?
可以，但我认为这对这里真的没关联。你觉得呢？
You don't think Amanda's wedding is relevant to the story of your manic phase after mom died?
你不觉得阿曼达的婚礼与妈妈去世后你经历的狂躁阶段的故事有关联吗？
Well, I mean, all right. You start it off.
嗯，我是说，好吧。你开始说吧。
I understand why he's hesitant. It's the only thing he did during that period that still embarrasses him. My dad loves weddings. They're his Super Bowl. It was for my best friend, Amanda, and my dad was the unofficial father of the bride. He was also, as always, filming the wedding. Those three cameras were back, baby. So we were all on the dance floor outside, and he was in his element, the life of the party. And then, suddenly, I couldn't find him.
我理解他为什么要犹豫。这是他在那个时期做的唯一让他现在还感到尴尬的事。我爸爸热爱婚礼。那是他的“超级碗”。那是为了我最好的朋友阿曼达，我爸爸是非官方的伴郎。他也是，像往常一样，在拍摄婚礼。那三个摄像机又回来了，宝贝。所以我们都在外面的舞池里，他是舞池之魂，派对的焦点。然后，突然，我找不到他了。
To my horror, I looked up and found he'd made his way into the house, where no one was allowed, and was standing in this room that overlooked the dance floor. He was framed by huge floor-to-ceiling windows, like a fishbowl, and my dad had turned this living room into his own personal stage. He was hoisting up what looked like a dead body, but it turned out to be a bridesmaid he'd rolled up in an area rug so that just her head was popping out. Thankfully, she was in on the bit.
令我惊恐的是，我抬头发现他进了房子，那里是不允许进去的。他站在那个俯瞰舞池的房间里。他被巨大的落地窗框住，就像一个鱼缸，我爸爸把这间客厅变成了他个人的舞台。他举着一个看起来像尸体的东西，但结果是一个被他卷进地毯里的伴娘，只露出了头。谢天谢地，她是配合演出的。
He proceeded to bob her back and forth between his arms, like the way you see guys on the boardwalk try to juggle a stick between two other sticks. And then, unfortunately, he stuck an empty beer bottle through the zipper of his pants and pretended to pee. Everyone was laughing, but it wasn't funny. It felt scary to see him like that. My brother, my friend's uncle, and I raced into the house, and we dragged him out across the giant lawn. And he started putting on this baby voice, saying, me no want to stop having fun, just begging us to go back to the party.
他继续在双臂之间来回颠动她，就像你在木板路上看到的人试图在两根棍子之间耍弄一根棍子一样。然后，不幸的是，他把一个空啤酒瓶塞进裤子拉链里假装小便。大家都笑了起来，但那并不好笑。看到他那样真令人害怕。我弟弟、我朋友的叔叔和我冲进房子，把他拖过巨大的草坪。他开始用那种婴儿腔说：我不要停止玩乐，乞求我们要回派对去。
We finally got him to agree to go home. And as he was getting on the bus, he turned to us and asked if we would hold his camera equipment for a second so he could tie his shoe. The moment our hands were full, he did a fake out, and he took off running back across the lawn, jumping over hedges to get to the party, yelling, I'm free! I'm free! Turned out the hedges were filled with poison ivy, which landed him in the hospital the next day. I didn't know until we talked that this moment changed something for my dad. He realized--
我们终于让他同意回家。当他上车时，他转向我们，问我们能不能帮他拿一下摄影器材，这样他能系鞋带。当我们双手拿满东西的瞬间，他耍了个把戏，转身跑回草坪，跳过树篱回到派对，喊着：我自由了！我自由了！结果树篱里长满了毒藤，导致他第二天住进了医院。我直到我们交谈时才知道这一刻改变了我爸爸的某些东西。他意识到——
What am I doing here? Maybe I'm a little out of control. And I started to say, I better bring it down a couple of notches.
我在这里做什么？也许我有点失控了。我开始对自己说：我最好把节奏放慢一点。
So that night really was kind of this turning point for you, huh? That's so interesting.
所以那天晚上确实算是你的一个转折点，对吧？真有意思。
I think so. That was certainly one that slowed me down, and which I needed at that point. Yep.
我想是的。那绝对是一个让我慢下来的时刻，而我在那一点上正需要这个。是的。
I really do think that was also a big moment for me because it was just the moment that I really gave up. I was just like, I can't control this man anymore. It doesn't feel good to do that to you, and I also simply can't. I don't think anyone can. One of the reasons I wanted to talk to you-- because I think when mom died we just grieved her very differently. I really was hell bent that you were grieving wrong and I was grieving right, and I'm kind of laying in bed and feeling, and you're not feeling, to my eye, how I was.
我真的认为那对我也是一个重大时刻，因为那就是我真正放弃的时刻。我当时就是觉得：我再也不能控制这个人了。那样对你做感觉不好，而且我也根本做不到。我不认为任何人能做到。我想和你交谈的原因之一——因为我认为妈妈去世时我们哀悼她的方式非常不同。我真的认定了你在错误地哀悼，而我在正确地哀悼，我躺在床上感觉，你看起来不像我那样在感受。
Well, I think it was just a different process for me. And I felt-- I felt the grief, but I also felt this compulsion, almost, to be the funny man, to live a little bit. And at the same time that there is this tremendous sadness, there is the beginning of a little freedom. It just felt different, kind of pleasant, to be free of shackles.
嗯，我认为那对我来说是一个不同的过程。我感到了哀悼，但我同时也感到了某种强迫性，几乎是必须成为那个搞笑的人，必须活下去。同时，在巨大的悲伤中，有一点自由的开始。它只是感觉不同，从束缚中解脱出来，感觉挺愉快的。
I guess I sort of-- the reason I thought it felt wrong to me was even when you say you wanted to feel free of shackles, it sort of implies that mom was your shackles as opposed to grieving mom, in a way.
我想我大概——我之所以认为这对我来说感觉不对，是因为即使你说你想从束缚中解脱出来，这在某种意义上暗示了妈妈是你的束缚，而不是哀悼妈妈。
Yeah, and I don't mean it to be your mom. But it was just the notion that there were constraints on how all of us live our life, and the constraints were off.
是的，我并不意指你的妈妈。但这就是一种观念，即我们所有人过生活都有约束，而约束消失了。
What he means is that when the stable, suburban life he'd built for himself suddenly shattered, he thought, if I have to start over, then I'm just going to do me. He got this idea, I was surprised to learn, from someone at my mom's wake.
他的意思是，当他为自己建立的稳定郊区生活突然破碎时，他想：如果我必须重新开始，那我就做回我自己。我惊讶地得知，这个想法来自于我妈妈葬礼上的某个人。
A woman who had lost her husband not that long ago, about 14, 15 months earlier, she came up to hug me. And I remember asking her, when does it get easier? And she just said, it doesn't. And that said it all.
一个不久前，大约14、15个月前失去丈夫的女人走过来拥抱我。我记得问她：什么时候会变容易？她只是说：不会。这就说明了一切。
So he decided, why not enjoy life? In all those times I thought I was being helpful and protecting him, I was actually making things worse.
所以他决定，为什么不享受生活？在所有那些我以为我在帮助他、保护他的时间里，我实际上把事情弄糟了。
I think what made me a little angry at times was how you wanted to control me and control my emotions, and they weren't controllable.
我想让我有时感到生气的是你想要控制我、控制我的情绪，而它们是不可控制的。
Yeah. Would you say I treated you kind of like a child?
是的。你会说我把你像孩子一样对待吗？
No. Maybe just a little bit. But you were trying to kind of keep me on the rails, keep me in a straight and narrow. And I felt like you were trying to say, no, no. This is how you have to feel. You have to be very sad.
不。也许只是有一点点。但你试图让我保持在轨道上，保持在笔直狭窄的道路上。我觉得你试图说：不，不。你必须这样感受。你必须非常悲伤。
Yeah. And what did you feel about me and how I kind of handled it and did it? Did grief, if you will.
是的。那你对我处理这件事的方式感觉如何？如果你愿意的话，是对“哀悼”这件事。
You were pretty consistent in not liking anything.
你一直都很不喜欢任何事情。
Were you worried about me?
你为我担心吗？
Very much so. Yeah. When someone's sleeping in their closet, I think that's cause for concern.
非常担心。是的。当一个人睡在衣柜里时，我认为那值得担忧。
From your perspective, from where you were at, did you feel like I was grieving wrong?
从你的角度看，从你的处境看，你是否觉得我在错误地哀悼？
Yeah, I guess I did. I mean, I didn't feel like it was the most noble thing to be sleeping in your closet for over a year.
是的，我想我确实这么认为。我是说，我觉得在衣柜里睡了一年多不是什么高尚的事情。
You were very disturbed by that. As were--
你对此感到非常不安。正如——
Yeah, I thought it was--
是的，我觉得那是——
--friends.
——朋友们。
--thought it was disturbing
——我觉得那是令人不安的。
I know. But isn't it funny, at the time, I thought, there's nothing weird about this at all. It's not weird at all that I found a twin-sized mattress in the garage of my building, and I have it sticking half in the closet, half out. And before I would go to bed, I would just take a swig of this NyQuil every night, and then I would go through her datebook just to see her handwriting and to see all the upcoming events. It's almost like a mystery you want to put together, and I'd think, oh-- you know, it would say, Fletcher's graduation and doctor's appointments. And you're just kind of like, wow, to not, not that this is such an original thought, but to have no notion or knowledge or something sad about someone planning out a future that's just never to be.
我知道。但不是很有趣吗，当时我想，这完全没什么奇怪的。我在大楼车库里找到一个双人床垫，把它半塞进衣柜、半露在外面，这根本不奇怪。而且在睡觉前，我每晚都会喝一口止咳糖浆，然后翻看她的日程本，只是为了看她的字迹和所有即将到来的事件。这几乎像你想拼凑起来的谜题，我会想：哦——你知道，上面会写着：弗莱彻的毕业典礼和医生预约。你就是会觉得，哇，即便这不是什么原创的想法，但对于一个人计划一个永远无法实现的未来，那种没有概念、没有知识、或者某种悲伤的感觉，真让人心碎。
While you can put a label on my dad's route of mania, you can also put a label on mine. Depression. In a way, they are two sides of the same coin. For my dad to have fun, go out on dates, I don't know. Maybe it was healthier.
虽然你可以给爸爸的狂躁路径贴上标签，你也可以给我的路径贴上标签。抑郁。在某种意义上，它们是同一枚硬币的两面。为了让我爸爸玩得开心、出去约会，我不知道。也许那样更健康。
Why did it upset you so that you thought somebody was replacing your mom? Why did it bother you so that, you know--
为什么你觉得有人在替代你妈妈让你如此不安？为什么它困扰你到那个地步，你知道——
Oh, it was horrible. It was horrible. Horrible to think of. Unfathomable. I really had it in my head that to move on was like an insult to mom, as opposed to you moving forward because you had to. It was excruciating.
哦，那太可怕了。那太可怕了。想到它就太可怕了。深不可测。我确实在脑子里认定继续前进就像是对妈妈的侮辱，而不是因为你必须继续前进所以你向前走了。那太痛苦了。
Well, I can appreciate what you're saying. Yeah. Yeah.
嗯，我能理解你说的。是的。是的。
But I do feel I was too hard on you now that I'm married. And I really am of the mind now, God, however anybody has to get through this is the right way.
但我现在结婚了，我觉得我当时对你太苛刻了。我现在真的认为，天哪，无论谁以什么方式熬过去，那都是正确的方式。
Yeah, that's right.
是的，那是对的。
And just, you know, there is no way.
而且，你知道，没有“正确”的方式。
Yeah. There is no way.
是的。没有那种方式。
It wasn't until eight years after my mom's death that our grief lifted a little. Not all of it. It will always be there. But I remember the moment that it lifted enough to finally feel like it wasn't crushing us. It happened on a trip my brother Fletcher, my dad, and I took to the beach. It was just the three of us, our family now, missing a limb. On the plane, my dad told us that he had met someone, a woman named Marjorie, a speechwriter and professor. And we could tell in his voice that this woman was different.
直到妈妈去世八年后，我们的哀悼才减轻了一点。不是全部。它将永远存在。但我记得那种减轻到终于让人觉得它不再压垮我们的时刻。那发生在我和哥哥弗莱彻、爸爸去海滩的一次旅行中。只有我们三个，我们现在的家庭，缺了一条肢体。在飞机上，爸爸告诉我们他遇到了某个人，一个叫马乔里的女人，一位演讲稿撰写人和教授。我们能从他的声音中听出这个女人与众不同。
He was in love. And for the first time, I was flooded with happiness for my dad that he was moving on. By this point, I was also dating my now-husband, David, and my brother shared that when he got home from this trip, he was going to propose to his now-wife, Kathleen. And so I remember on this trip, there was a feeling in the air that this would be the last trip just the three of us. We didn't talk about it, but we knew. We all scuba dive, and I remember the dive we went on. There we were, 100 feet below the surface.
他坠入了爱河。这是第一次，我为爸爸感到幸福，因为他正在继续前进。到这个时候，我也在和我现在的丈夫大卫约会，我弟弟分享说，当他这次旅行回家时，他会向他现在的妻子凯瑟琳求婚。所以我记得在这次旅行中，空气中有一种感觉，这将是我们三个人的最后一次旅行。我们没谈论这个，但我们都知道。我们都潜水，我记得我们去潜水的那次。我们就在那里，水面以下100英尺。
It was very calm. But I turned and looked to my right and was shocked to see a literal abyss, just a cliff and darkness below. It was eerie. But we drifted away from it and kept swimming, alternating who was ahead and who was behind. And that's how I like to think of us, swimming together towards the surface.
非常平静。但我转过身看向右边，震惊地看到一个真正的深渊，下面只是悬崖和黑暗。那令人毛骨悚然。但我们漂离了它，继续游泳，轮流谁在前面谁在后面。我喜欢这样想我们，一起向水面游去。
Casey Wilson is the author of the memoir The Wreckage of My Presence. You can also see her in The Shrink Next Door on Apple TV.
凯西·威尔逊是回忆录《我的存在残骸》的作者。你也可以在Apple TV的《隔壁心理医生》中看到她。
[MUSIC - "LOST MY WAY" BY BONNY DOON]
[音乐 - Bonny Doon的《迷失方向》]
Well, today's program was produced by Elna Baker with help from Chris Benderev. The people who put together today's program include Dana Chivvis, Sean Cole, Michal Comite, Rebecca Davis, Aviva DeKornfeld, Kyla Jones, Tobin Low, Michelle Navarro, Stowe Nelson, Katherine Rae Mondo, Alix Spiegel, Robyn Semien, Alissa Shipp, Christopher Swetala, Matt Tierney, Julie Whitaker, and Diane Wu. Our managing editor is Sarah Abdurrahman. Our senior editor is David Kestenbaum. Our executive editor is Emanuele Berry. Special thanks today to Ari Saperstein, George Green, Steve Callahan, Nadia Wilson, Lauren Spohrer, Nick Pyenson, Laela Sayigh, Mark Elliott, and Madeleine Dong.
今天的节目由艾尔娜·贝克制作，克里斯·本德雷夫提供帮助。参与今天节目的人包括达娜·奇维斯、肖恩·科尔、米歇尔·科米特、丽贝卡·戴维斯、阿维瓦·德科恩菲尔德、凯拉·琼斯、托宾·洛、米歇尔·纳瓦罗、斯托·尼尔森、凯瑟琳·雷·蒙多、阿利克斯·斯皮格尔、罗宾·塞米恩、阿丽莎·希普、克里斯托弗·斯威塔拉、马特·蒂尔尼、朱莉·惠特克和黛安·吴。我们的执行编辑是萨拉·阿卜杜拉赫曼。资深编辑是戴维·凯斯滕鲍姆。执行编辑是埃马努埃莱·贝里。特别感谢今天的所有人。
Yibin Li, who you heard at the beginning of our show, runs the OneMusic Project, which is musicians from around the world trying to bring chamber music to a bigger audience. Our website, thisamericanlife.org, where you can stream our archive of over 750 programs for absolutely free. Also, there's videos, there's lists of favorite shows if you're looking for something to listen to, tons of other stuff there. Again, thisamericanlife.org. This American Life is delivered to public radio stations by PRX, the Public Radio Exchange. Thanks, as always, to our program's co-founder, Mr. Torey Malatia, who has a foolproof strategy for playing Marco Polo.
依彬·李，你在节目开头听到的那位，经营着OneMusic Project，这是来自世界各地的音乐家试图将室内乐带给更多观众的项目。我们的网站 thisamericanlife.org，在那里你可以完全免费流媒体播放我们超过750个节目的存档。此外，还有视频，如果你想听什么，还有最喜欢的节目列表，上面有海量内容。再说一次，thisamericanlife.org。《美国生活》由PRX，公共广播交换中心发送给公共广播电台。像往常一样感谢我们节目的联合创始人，托雷·马拉蒂亚先生，他有一个玩“马可波罗”游戏的万无一失的策略。
You start swimming in a huge circle, and that makes it more difficult for anyone to find you.
你开始游一个巨大的圈，这让任何人找到你都变得更困难。
I'm Ira Glass, back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯，下周带着更多《美国生活》的故事回来。
[MUSIC - "LOST MY WAY" BY BONNY DOON]
[音乐 - Bonny Doon的《迷失方向》]